Hey David, is there a mass shooting deadly
enough to get Republicans to support gun control?
Unfortunately, the opposite might be true.
We are sort of thinking about this as like,
okay, um, when we see evidence of a problem,
we try to solve that problem in the way that
seems logical to us. So we see all of these
countries with low gun ownership and strict
gun safety laws have no mass shootings or
almost no mass shootings. And then that makes
us say, wow, we should look at doing some
of that stuff in the u s to solve problem
of mass shootings.
There's a fundamental problem here in that
the pro gun fetishists don't see gun control
as the solution to mass shootings. So the
idea of if there's a really bad mass shooting,
then all of a sudden the gun fetishists will
stop wanting more guns. They'll want gun safety.
No. In fact, the opposite is likely to happen.
The worst mass shooting, the worst the mass
shootings get rather the more guns that the
pro gun fetishists might want because they
see the guns as the solution to the mass shootings.
Things like gun free zones create soft targets
for mass shooters. People not having their
own weapons create an environment where a
mass shooter won't be scared that everybody
might be armed and someone might take them
out before he is able to do damage or whatever
else. So I actually reject the idea that the
problem getting worse will lead to the pro
gun.
Right. Changing their mind. After Sandy Hook
Obama had a, a the presidency and he had the
house, not House and Senate, uh, and he was
not able to pass a universal background checks
even though there was like 90% support for
those in the United States at that time. That
includes a lot of right-wingers. And so this
problem is far bigger. It's the culture. It's
the gun lobbying organizations, which exists
basically to sell guns. No organization that
exists to increase the number of gun sales
is ever going to advocate for any policy that
might restrict the number of people that can
get guns or the number of guns that can be
sold. There's an idea that a bunch of people
tweeted me when I said I'm going to be answering
this question on the show, and they said it's
urban versus rural. This is merely a question
of in urban areas where police are closer,
people are less likely to believe that they
are going to need guns to protect themselves.
Whereas rural where police may be much further
away, it is just a a different situation.
Yes and no because remember on the one hand
Bernie Sanders has said gun ownership in rural
Vermont is different than gun ownership in
America cities, and that's true in many ways,
but you don't get 90% agreement for universal
100% on every transaction background checks
with only urban people in the United States.
Rural people are also apart. You're not going
to get 90% with only people. Living in cities
is the point. What might actually, and I,
I hate to say this, but what might actually
change things is if large groups of minorities
start to not only arm themselves but make
a big show of it, do it, uh, in the same way
that a lot of these right wing, mostly white
groups do it, the open carry displays or whatever.
I'm not for any of that stuff.
I hate it. I think it's disgusting. I think
it's a waste of people's lives that that's
how they want to be activists, to walk around
with guns visible in a Walmart or wherever
else on the street, whatever the case may
be. But I think that a lot of the, uh, sort
of hardcore conservative white gun owners,
if all of a sudden gun ownership becomes a
thing of large groups of minority gun owners
publicly displaying their firearms, some of
them will defend it on principle. I know,
but a lot of them aren't going to like it.
And it's funny because a lot of people tweeted
me, David, you know what, we'll change things
if all of a sudden armed black militia groups,
armed Latino militia groups in border states
start making big displays of their open caring
where it is legal of course. And I actually
think that that might actually influence a
lot of people to start saying, wait, hold
on a second.
We've got to reconsider this. Although of
course they would reconsider it only in the
most hypocritical way. They don't want those
other people doing it. They would still want
it for themselves, but it might actually shake
things up enough that you might at least get
some new conversations instead of the talking
point conversations we're stuck in now gun,
uh, mass shooting the guns aren't the problem.
The fact that it was a gun free zone is the
problem. Uh, okay. But what about banning
these types of weapons? Those weapons are
often not the ones actually used in the crimes.
Okay. Well what about ammunition? A lot of
that stuff is after my, it's like the same
talking point conversations that go nowhere.
Maybe that would actually change that up.
Let me know what you think. Let me know what
you think would actually change the mind of
a pro gun right-wing fetishist on this issue.